what is President Trump trying to tell
his own attorney general Jeff Sessions
well there's been a pattern of continued
public berating of the Attorney General
by the president a pattern that
continued in an interview with The Wall
Street Journal on Tuesday in which the
president said again that he's
disappointed that attorney general
sessions has recused himself from the
investigation of Russian meddling in the
2016 election and that he's disappointed
he's not going after leakers of
classified intelligence here's how the
president put his attitude and I'm very
disappointed in Jeff sessions you can
fire look Jeff we'll see what happens
but I was I appointed a man to a
position and then shortly after he gets
the position he recused himself I said
what's that all about
why didn't you tell me that you were
gonna do that and I wouldn't have
appointed you but I appointed him and
shortly thereafter the president has
also said by the way that he wishes the
Attorney General would do more
investigation of some what unspecified
misdeeds by Hillary Clinton his opponent
in the 2016 election it seems pretty
obvious that the president hopes
attorney general sessions will simply
quit will he fire him well as he said in
that passage just now he's willing to
fire him but that would be very
complicated to create two problems for
the president the first is it would
create charges that he's politicizing
the legal and law enforcement machinery
of the federal government and second
like his firing of FBI director James
Comey it were produced democratic
charges that it amounts to an
obstruction of justice and attempt to
block a full investigation of whatever
Russia's role was in the 2016 campaign
and whether it was there to help the
Trump campaign or not so firing jeff
Sessions very possible also very
complicated